most currencies were started just
because people trusted them it was like
the promise of gold or started out being
shells and you know then it was gold and
then it was the promise of gold now it
was a promise that the government would
back you up which is a little less of a
promise well and that was a given
government and that government was tied
to a geographic territory all of a
sudden we have a currency that is not
tied to a government and not tied to a
geographic territory
well that frees us because governments
have always used that currency to
control us to in some ways keep keep
controls over that currency well this
frees us we can we can operate a
cross-border much easily we can move
money across border much easily much
more easily and and we reduce the
friction significantly you know you know
you wonder why are those banks so big
and those bankers also rich why are they
all dressed so well well it's because 2
and a half to 4 percent of every
transaction you ever do is picked up by
the credit card company and the bank
gets the bulk of that that would go away
and so you do see the the banks feeling
threatened here and for good reason
because if you use Bitcoin instead of
dollars you the banker doesn't control
your Bitcoin he controls your dollars so
I think you have this new opportunity
for a currency that is is frictionless
not no two and a half to four percent
transparent everybody can see exactly
where it goes so you keep perfect
records it is open its cross-border so
you can use it anywhere you can go from
one country to another pull down your
Bitcoin and everything's fine and and
it's a great store of value but it's
also going to be faster than the visa
Network so this is going to be one of
things where it's like it's a sea-change
that there is new technology and it is
better faster cheaper than anything else
out there we're going to move that way
and governments have to figure out how
they're going to adapt to not
controlling everybody through the
currency